Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
And Ah,
I'm just checking in on you.
Hey Bill,
dude.
What the fuck?
Why are you checking in on is so fucking late this week,
dude,
what'd you have a fucking hernia?
Is that what happened?
What did you,
did you get hit by a car?
Uh,
no.
I,
it's been the most difficult podcasts I've ever had to record you guys.
I need a start up for my emotions.
Um,
honestly,
uh,
I don't know what happened.
I fucking,
I got real busy and then I recorded the podcast and for some reason there was no
audio.
I can't figure out what the fuck I did to mine.
Oh,
I did something.
freckles did something.
So this is my second attempt.
The last attempt was,
believe it or not,
I believe was on Thursday hours on Wednesday.
I swear to God the dog ate my homework.
That's literally what I'm [inaudible]
telling you in a podcasting way.
Um,
so I'm back to a,
one of my original mixers here.
Thank God I didn't throw it out.
Thank God I'm a bit of a pack rat you guys.
No,
actually I didn't want to throw it out because I was going to give it away to
somebody.
What I wanted to do.
That was the thing I was going to be like.
Do you mind?
You realize the amount of times a semi known comic said the word cunt into this
mixer,
mixer.
And I thought it'd be worth something to somebody that they would take it.
Um,
but I never got around to doing that.
And thank God I had a backup mixer.
All right.
That's the level that I'm bawling at right now.
Yeah,
you got to mix it,
buddy.
I got a mixer and a backup mixer.
What the fuck do you got?
You know,
if they still had MTV cribs right now,
I would be on it.
Yeah.
Lifestyles of the rich and famous,
they have one and a half mixes.
Um,
all right,
it's Saturday,
Saturday.
All right.
In more freckles has been,
uh,
alcohol free for nine miserable fucking weeks.
It's actually,
you know,
something,
I'm at the point now,
I don't even give a shit.
I don't think I think about it occasionally,
but now when I think about it,
I think,
but why would I go back to that?
Huh?
Oh,
Billy booze face sitting back and joy and himself after a long day of hard work
of performing words that other people wrote.
Do you guys realize,
realize how hard it is to be an actor sometimes to just show up and say things
that people already said for you on a piece of paper.
Um,
that's one of the reasons why this week's a little crazy.
A,
I got a little acting gig over the next,
uh,
week or so,
and I'm on general hospital.
Um,
no,
and I'm not allowed to say everything.
You're not allowed to say now because you've got all these fucking cops.
Everybody tries to figure out what you're on and then they start,
I don't know what they do.
And somehow they know
what you're doing before you even shoot it.
That's like the level of technology.
Okay.
If you actually say what you're acting on and somebody's listening to you on a
podcast has a drone with one of those Gopros,
somehow they will know what senior doing the next day before you are before you
do.
Okay.
Speaking of drones,
do you know that the next level of Uber,
the next level of lift,
the next level of fucking is early to fucking,
there's only two of them.
You either take lifter waste.
It's like back in the day when there was VHS or Beta and everybody chose VHS.
So think about that.
The next time you're going to get in a car with a stranger.
Huh?
Um,
there's a bunch of weird movies coming out now that I don't understand.
You know,
there's a fucking documentary right now in,
in,
uh,
in Sundance.
It's,
I,
I can't,
I glanced at it quickly.
I think it said it was four hours long.
It can't be four hours long.
It's a documentary about two now adults who said when they were kids,
they allegedly got molested by Michael Jackson.
Now I gotta ask you this,
why the fuck would I want to sit down and watch that?
I'm going to sit there with a bucket of popcorn and some fucking junior mints.
All right,
let me hear the worst story that can happen to a kid,
you know,
and you know,
some people say,
oh,
they just do it for my,
I don't know what the fuck happened.
I wasn't there,
but let's,
you know,
true or untrue.
I don't want to listen to those stories.
Okay.
What kind of a fucking person wants to fucking sit down?
Yeah.
You go to the movies,
you know you're going to get something to eat
and just sitting there at the camp.
Oh,
what do you feel like indulging in before we listened to this horror?
MMM.
I Dunno,
but I go back to,
I think when I saw Schindler's list,
I believe I was eating popcorn.
I mean that this certain movies,
they should not,
you should not be sitting there stuffing your face with food,
right?
We now have a documentary about the genocide in Rwanda and out of respect for
the victims than are you fat Americans?
Will be allowed to eat over the next two hours.
Aw,
everybody fucking groans.
Hashtag hypoglycemic.
Um,
anyways,
so they,
they uh,
getting back to the drones,
the next level of Uber is that they're actually gonna have,
I swear to God,
like unmanned
drones,
I guess none of them really mad right now that you can get into like a life size
one,
like a human size one and you get in this fucking thing and you fly all over the
traffic.
Like,
like I do when I fly one of the Helio type copters and I have to tell you this,
you are out of your fucking mind.
If you remember the Lasik eye surgery when that first came out,
do you remember that?
And they'd be a couple of fucking people go,
oh my God,
I can see it to the future.
But like one out of every 15 would be like,
Mike,
why don't you,
I'll never see again.
Yeah.
This is going to be the first week of Lasik eye surgery version of that.
I want to know how in the fuck the FAA is going to fucking sign off on that one.
You know,
God damn well there's,
it was a glitch.
The hats just blue.
You're going to have the Gus Grissom fucking,
something's going to happen.
You know,
it's bad enough that you're going to have the person up there careening down or
falling down to the death.
You can be sitting there fucking watching NFL football up.
But DAP at at bed,
having a fucking hipsters gonna fall through your goddamn ceiling.
Tight jeans and all,
you know,
Hitler youth fucking fade with the A,
I know how to make shoes by,
by hand.
Beard that he thought he's going to have.
It's going to come fallen right through your fucking ceiling.
I don't know.
You know,
you know,
you'd think if fucking people like Elon Musk are trying to figure out a way to
drill through the Goddamn earth and now they're going to have unmanned,
unmanned people,
unmanned devices,
flying people around up there.
Why you think it's some people at some point,
Jesus Christ,
the kids speak,
somebody would address the fucking population problem
signs.
You have too many people.
Uh,
we're going to have unmanned drones flying people over densely populated areas.
Hey everybody,
you have cell phones,
you have laptops.
How many times?
What's the longest they've consistently worked before you had to refresh it
or shut it down or restart it or take it over to the apple store.
So one of the geniuses can be like,
oh,
I find them,
I found the problem.
People in aviation,
you can't hit a refresh button.
Okay.
Yeah.
They refresh.
They refreshed by hosing off wherever the fuck you crash landed.
Let's refresh this scorched earth.
Um,
and then it will be like,
well,
should they installed the horror struck today when to hipsters from several acre
.
We're trying to get from silver lake out to Santa Monica to go to a craft beer
tasting fucking festival,
whatever the,
whatever the fuck it is they do
to go to a pocket watch convention.
Yeah.
And then not follow it through.
Some fucking,
you know,
on,
you're not paid in a month.
Air traffic control is fucking a irony struck today.
Um,
I dunno.
Audio,
you're out of your fucking mind.
And I also got to think it's going to be at least 300 bucks per trip.
That'll become some elite thing and then there'll be like,
you know,
we have to have affordable,
unmanned drones.
Why are you saying unmanned bill?
You know why?
Because man learned how to fly,
not women.
And I'm sure when Hollywood does the fucking next bio pic of Orville and Wilbur,
it'll be like,
well why can't it be Orval in Wilma?
And they'll make one of them a woman and they'll make some sort of backstory
that one of them actually identified as female just so they don't get yelled at
on Twitter or villain Wilma.
We're very proud of this,
that the real story of fucking Devil's island,
whatever the fuck they call,
wherever they,
they actually,
where they learned how to fly is like some devils something or other.
Yeah,
no,
I'm sure there's some Jesus fucking group out there.
Jesus Freak Group.
We'll just talk.
Okay.
That's why you tell you right now let's swap.
Flight is evil.
Ain't you ever read the story of ICARUS?
They flew too close to the sun and his and his winged is wing base caught on
fire and he went all the way back down to earth and he continued to fall to
earth through the earth into the pits and the flames of hail.
Okay.
Um,
I dunno what I'm talking about and I don't give a shit.
I'm just contractually obligated here to give you guys some sort of an effort
for 30 minutes.
Okay.
That's what you get.
Not to me.
Oh by the way,
speaking of efforts Sunday,
tomorrow,
Sunday,
whatever,
fuck,
January 27 2019 this is the,
this is the soft open of a sports world without football for the next six
months.
This is the one
via giphy.
You know,
God bless Espn,
God bless Fox sports.
The way the way they're going to be keep yammering on on Sunday is if something
sports wise is actually happening in football.
Look down here at the trade at cap and
Rob Gradkowski is,
is touching his left hand to his right fucking clean.
Rob,
you find it harder to reach to the right one with your left hand or the left one
with your right hand.
I'm sorry,
rob.
Gronkowski he's not answering questions right now.
I mean,
who the fuck is going to sit around and watch that?
All right.
They used to at least have the goddamn pro bowl.
They had something going on.
Um,
but that's it.
People.
There's one more week event,
AFL football and there's only two teams left.
All right,
one left.
So you have to ask yourself,
who are you inviting to your Superbowl party?
Huh?
Are you going to have the balls
to fucking only invite sports fans?
I guess if your team isn't in it,
why do you give a shit?
Why not be social?
You know what I mean?
Why not have a bunch of people come over who don't give a fuck?
They're just there for the burgers that the radios,
the fucking hot dogs,
this stupid dips,
that fucking thing that somebody made that nobody really likes.
But they bring it every year and everybody's got to take at least one fucking
bite out of the thing.
Maybe.
Oh,
it's even fucking better than last year.
Yeah,
I think I'm thinking,
I'm toying with the idea of having people over.
It's going to be a select few.
All right.
And they will come in in unmanned drones and hopefully not fall
through the fucking roof of my house.
That's what I'm hoping.
That's what I'm hoping happens.
Now,
why the fuck is this?
This seems like the sound is down low on this one at Jesus Christ.
Who knows who the fuck knows?
I just want to thank all the brave men and women who make the mixers out there
who are fighting for my freedom and defending this country against terrorism.
How's that dude?
How much longer is this government shutdown going to lay?
This is like the most fucking petty Goddamn like,
and I don't understand too why if the government shuts down.
Okay.
Uh,
air traffic controllers and people like that,
they don't get paid,
but politicians continue to get fucking paid.
I bet.
I'll tell.
I'll go out on a limb here.
I'll bet.
Because there was some sort of legislation that a fucking politician paid
somebody to come up with and they all fucking agreed.
Yeah.
They all agreed to be like,
yes,
we will continue to get paid those fucking filthy cuts.
I still don't understand how somebody could actually be a Democrat or
Republican.
When you watch behavior like this feed actually just fucking sit there,
you know?
I mean,
I don't,
I'm going to sit here and I'm going,
what I'm going to do now is do whatever every fucking cunt does,
which is I'm going to state the obvious without a solution,
you know,
and act like I am above you.
All right?
That's what I mean.
I do that in general.
Just part of being a form of,
part of getting on stage,
part of being back and waiting for your name to be called and feeling that rush
of excitement that can only be described as someone else who has taken the
stage.
Um,
you know,
when you speak into a this,
this,
you just feel like you know things.
All right?
And I apologize to all of you poor people out there who never in your life where
you ever know the thrill of not reading and simply turning on a device,
speaking into a microphone,
recording yourself.
You know,
I feel bad for you.
I respect all of you.
You know,
you put your pants on one leg at a time,
you know Joe six pack Shuggie.
You get through at least four beers before you physically abused the woman in
your life.
You know the regular joes out their lunch pail Larry,
right?
Ham Hock Harry,
you know fucking,
yeah,
Capri Sun,
Sandra Capri Sun.
Where the fuck did I pull that out of that?
I don't know.
I know I never got into those fucking juices back in the day.
I'll let fucking weird shit.
People used to eat over those things during lunchtime.
30 fucking years ago in the cafeteria I'd go to,
it would literally be what they call fruit rollups.
You said this shit fruit rollups and I swear to God it looked like wax.
These people would just fucking just be,
I don't know what it was.
It was,
it was some sort of fruit infused flavor with like a pound of sugar.
And then,
uh,
I dunno,
earwax from fucking workers in a third world plant or some shit.
I don't know what it wasn't.
Kids would sit there and eat.
I mean,
you know what?
Nobody died.
And,
and,
and the world was actually was in a lot of ways,
was it better place?
I'm not saying we were as progressive
as we are today.
Okay.
Some would argue overly progressive.
And when I say some,
I would say a lot of the voices in my head would say,
I think we're going a little too far with this shit.
You know?
Oh,
you start giving actors shit for acting.
Why are you pretending to be something that you're not at?
Because it's acting that that is what acting is.
Okay.
If you,
if you take an acting job and you just act what you already are,
that's not really acting,
which is why so many people have done a decent job,
be in what they are on sprayed and then everybody thinks they can act.
Oh,
I can act
acted Zzz.
Remember when that chick from hall,
that crazy drug addicted chick from whole played the crazy drug addicted chicken
that fucking way.
She was unbelievable as it crate that crazy drug addicted chick I couldn't
believe about,
well she played a crazy drug addicted check.
Let's say every crazy drug addicted woman can then go on screen and there is a
certain level of fucking town.
Okay.
But don't put yourself on the same level that my left foot guy guy walks around
acting like a in for a fucking year before he's actually Abe Lincoln.
Okay.
Then you're going to just come in and play a heightened version of yourself.
What am I doing right now?
I am describing my acting career.
Um,
anyways,
how much time is that?
Oh Jesus Christ.
It's like fucking,
you know,
it's hilarious.
It's like five 50 in the morning and I got up to go to the gym.
I got to,
I got the acting Gig also happens today.
I just have a later call time.
So I was like,
I'm going to get up and go to the gym.
All right.
Cause I'm uh,
trying to get myself back in shape here.
Right.
So you remember the old Jimson I go to the gym everyday.
It's just become pop me life.
And if you don't want to be a fatty,
you go to the gym every day.
You can have a big body.
I called Jerry so I don't go every day.
I take one day off.
All right.
I figured even if the Lord needed to take one day off when he was creating the
universe is I'm sculpting
this
flower covered colored body.
Yeah.
Do you know how you know something?
All of these minorities out there with their pigment bitch moaning and
complaining.
I asked you this as a privileged white male,
do you understand how difficult it is to get shredded when you were as
transparent?
Is me?
Okay.
I could be in just as good as shape as some Hawaiian.
But because I am so pasty,
the world is never going to know it.
And do you understand how difficult that is?
For me,
when I walk out into the world,
it's like,
Hey,
I have a couple of abs too.
You just can't see them.
Yeah.
I want to get that Janet Jackson,
stomach makeup.
We just said,
you know,
get one of those people that,
when you almost have abs then they just spray paint him in.
I want to do that.
Right.
And then I'm going to do,
put it on a half shirt and do my dance cover of miss you much.
Uh,
miss you.
Oh,
hi miss you.
But I really miss you much.
Um,
I remember I had a crush on her when she was on different strokes.
I didn't like her when she was on,
uh,
good times.
You know what I mean?
And that cause she was younger with baby fat and you know,
cause we're basically the same age.
It was because she was broke.
Okay.
And I'm not,
I'm not trying to get with some,
yeah,
she was living in the projects then.
I liked her better when she was,
you know,
on different strokes,
interacting with super rich white people.
Then then me as a little white kid could relate like,
oh,
all right,
okay.
Oh,
now the world don't move to the beat.
Just one drum.
What might wrap you may not be right for some.
Um,
all right.
That was inadvertently one of the funnier things that I've said on this podcast,
but I'm sure someone will take it in the wrong way.
What are you saying?
You can't fall in love with someone because they live in the projects,
projects,
projects.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
That is how privileged I am.
You know,
if women can go into these fucking single buys,
these meat markets in one of their first questions they ask you when you run
into them is what do you do for a living?
You know?
Yeah.
How much fucking cake are you putting on the table?
They're swinging Dick.
Why?
Why can't I choose?
Okay,
why can't I choose my TV crushes?
Huh?
That's how I was.
I was an elitist with my TV crutches,
crushes,
you know,
fuck all those bitches on the Waltons.
But I would fuck anybody on Falcon crest and cloning the man.
Now the world don't move to the beat of just one drug.
Bunch of rich white people throwing each other in the pool in evening gowns.
I've never seen that one.
Is that when Joan Crawford in Morgan Fairchild had their infamous catfight,
you know
that I think gets reenacted on floats during the gay pride parade in every city.
Isn't that what they isn't that required?
They have to have one stereotypical thing.
All right.
Gay People,
gay men,
let's,
let's do what straight people think we're into.
Let's,
let's appease them so we can try to be a little more mainstream this year.
Oh Man.
That different strokes on when,
when it gets in your fucking head,
you just can't get it out,
you know?
But it's enjoyable.
Everybody's dead except the due to play in Willis.
That's kind of sad.
Yeah.
I guess I died next.
I think I'm the same age as Willis Willis drumming.
But booboo will is driven.
He's owned the only one left alive.
Yes,
he is.
You know something.
That's what I do when I watch me TV.
I try to see like,
who's the only guy left?
Oh,
that's a great fucking trivia thing.
Name TV shows where there's only one series regulars still alive.
Different strokes.
The Beverly hillbillies.
Why am I ain't gonna hang on.
Whoa,
whoa.
Hang on.
When I wow the fucking,
uh,
the dude.
Yeah.
You know,
that's how you right now,
that's how that shows you right now.
How hard show businesses.
You know what I mean?
Cause in the real world,
women outlive the men.
All right?
But this business is so fucking difficult
that
I said,
that doesn't make any sense.
Does it?
Okay,
well,
let's see.
Well the one chick overdosed and then the housekeeper,
she was like 93 when they started shooting that she fucking crushed it.
She had a great act and career.
You know,
she had two shows that made syndication.
She was on
a,
she was on,
uh,
the facts of life,
right?
You take the good,
you take the bad,
you take them both in there.
You have the facts of life.
You know,
do you know why that song was at that tempo?
Because when you really just slow that down,
that doesn't make any sense.
You take the good,
you take the bed,
you take a both and there you have the facts of life.
It's like,
wait,
what?
That doesn't mean anything,
but you speed speeded up,
take the go to take the bed,
you take a boat and there you had the facts that like,
oh,
that's catchy.
I don't feel like thinking the facts of life.
Um,
I know what you thinking.
Hey Bill,
you're wife is black.
We ended Tuesday on that show.
No,
I was not.
I like Joe Joe the mechanic.
I liked her riding the dirt bike,
the fucking tomboy.
I like Blair at first.
You know,
at first I like Blair,
but there was just something so fucking wholesome about her.
After awhile.
I was just like,
yeah,
Jesus Christ.
Can you imagine the fucking look?
She be given me a weekend to this.
Do you like how I'm entertaining the fact that a young freckled me could
actually dated Blair from um,
oh is that fucking show.
I just set it the facts of life.
All right.
I don't have any of you to talk about somebody to tell you about my TV crushes.
Back in the day.
Um,
I would occasionally watch Charlie's angels because even back then I was so
sexist
that I,
I couldn't get over the fact that I was watching these,
these women all made up running down the alleys,
tackling these fucking guys into trash cans.
You know,
having said that,
I obviously like Farrah Fawcett,
right?
But I was a Kate Jackson Fan.
She was sort of the first Demi Moore,
I feel,
you know,
the fucking Brunette with the smokey fucking voice.
And then the best was when she was on the rookies,
Baghdad at Butoh.
Do Bob,
uh,
that add add,
add,
add bad at it.
You know,
when I would love to have on the fucking podcast,
I would love to have the trumpet player from the 1970s who fucking just got in
with whatever studio and played half of those theme songs.
Dude,
if you weren't a fucking horn section living in la in the 70s.
Right?
And you just fucking,
and then they had all those cop shows you were working every fucking week.
You in that Bongo player,
the Bongo player was just crushed every time you fucking chased.
The suspect down a fucking alley.
They always were playing the congas and the bongos.
Right.
And then whenever they had the theme song for the show was the fucking horn
section.
Uh,
uh,
banana.
A banana trumpets.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
right.
Fucking horn players crushing it.
Walking around with polyester shirts with on Dowdy and naval.
Yet you medallion,
you little coke spoon,
right?
Don't go to bed with a price on your head.
No,
don't do it.
Um,
all right,
bill,
what are your predictions for the Superbowl?
You know me,
I never think my team's going to win.
I hope they win,
but I'll tell you right now,
they're going to have their heads.
Fuck,
love these rams of Los Angeles that I already make fun of those fucking,
those 30 something douchebags who in the rams jerseys who were crying.
They were getting all emotional and they're fucking girlfriends were comforting
them.
When the rams beat the sites,
it's like,
what the fuck are you credit such a typical Foti fucking La Douche bag?
It's like the rams had been back for three years.
They left in the 80s.
You're fucking 30 years old.
You don't remember these fucking people.
Oh my God,
God,
I've been waiting since I was 26 and now I'm
29.
Yeah.
Now the world don't move to the beat of just one drum.
Your team just moved back.
Stop with the crocodile tears.
That's the wrong expression.
Stop with your phone.
He fucking tears.
Those were actors.
That's where they weren't in the NFL,
of course,
has to show them,
look how happy we make people.
And now let's take a veteran out of the crowd and charge the marines money for
it.
Ladies.
Gentlemen,
how about a round of applause for this hair?
All that.
We're now charging the military a fee for a commercial act.
A likely support.
Let's bring out the American flag everybody and whore out people's patriotism so
we can make more money.
Let's settle this class.
Action.
So with former players,
that comes down to about $38 per player.
Yeah.
Um,
oh Geez,
I'm getting cynical.
29 minutes.
Ah,
we made another one.
You know what?
I got to read a little advertising here.
Um,
I can be broken my own mother fucker.
That's how I,
I,
I justify my crush,
my elitist crush on Janet Jackson.
All right,
here we go.
He looks everybody Helux.
Yeah.
Hey man,
you ever wake up in the morning with a raging hot?
No.
You ever wake up in the morning with regrets and what you'd done?
Do you know what I did this morning?
I woke up this morning,
I had a dream that one of my relatives was on a boat that sank with like 200
fucking people and they were all missing and somehow I was in the ocean but
still in my house.
And I found my loved one and they picked her up and she was face down and when I
turned her over,
she started crying and was coughing and she was still alive.
And I came in and I think I talked shit.
I talked the other rescuers I said beat that.
And then I realized she was still alive and I started crying.
And then I really just started wailing,
crying.
And I walked by my mother and she just went,
Jay says,
Bill,
like I was crying too much.
Yeah.
I don't even get supported by drapes.
I'm replaying the terrible decisions you made the previous night over and over
and over.
The kicking,
the sweating,
the yelling or whatever else you did to piss everyone off to piss everyone in
the bedroom off.
Well,
guess what,
Bud?
Depending deciding to sleep on a shitty mattress is your choice.
I like how these people try to write this dialogue like the weight I talk.
So now I have to take my head away from the microphone and read literally what
they wrote.
But bill,
buying a mattress is so high.
Where would I ever begin?
Well,
you're in luck buddy.
A lot of buds and buddy here.
It's written by Jeff Spicoli.
What's your problem?
Bird.
Because Helen's helix sleep.
Um,
the mattress I've been yelling at you to buy for almost two years will challenge
your life.
Just go to helix,
sleep.com/burr.
Take their two minutes sleep quiz and they'll match you to the perfect mattress.
It's like Tinder for finding a mattress.
All the fun with none of the next morning regrets and misery.
And right now you can get up to $125 off your mattress order on helic sleep
helix.com/bar they have a 100 night trial grouse free shipping and won't send
you creepy texts the next day.
That's helix
sleep.com/burr for up to $125 off your mattress.
They let you try that.
You got a hundred night free trial.
Ah Ah,
ah.
It
doesn't feel right.
We don't want our bag and my broad,
it just doesn't feel right in my cock,
you know?
Well what kind of balls do you have?
I got those medium size ones but for some reason they weigh down my ball sack as
if it's not a quality ball sack.
You know like I feel like if I had a quality ball sack the weight of my balls,
they wouldn't be mid thigh.
It actually makes me know,
do they in plastic surgery?
Am I going to see one of the male Kardashians go down there and get a ball tuck,
a ball sack Tuck,
you know,
do you have a wrinkly ball sack?
That is so 2018,
come on down and get botox,
Gabby a balls,
botox.
Just listen to what these women have to say.
I never used to lick my husband's balls,
but now that so smooth and not Harry,
I'm down there every night taint.
Um,
all right.
That was my nod to David Cross and Bob Odenkirk.
One of the hardest I've ever laughed in a sketch show
is when they did that fucking sketch about the guy with the giant tape in the
porn industry and how they went.
It was,
it was not that sketch.
I didn't even hear that sketch.
It's the way they went into that sketch where they had like a Batman style
fight.
I can't really remember what happened,
but like you know they were doing the freeze frame on the,
on the,
on the punches they go pow bef you know,
Slam.
And then the last one,
this dude look like he kicked the guy in the balls and it just said taint and I
was fucking screaming,
laughing because taint was in the white world,
a very not known reference at that point,
if I remember correctly.
That came out of the African American community,
you know,
taint pussy tape balls.
It's the taint.
Right?
And that was new to white people.
And I was not ready for,
I think Patrice told me that one.
And I wasn't ready,
uh,
for that to be coming out of that show.
And I was screaming,
laughing,
and my lady at the time who was Caucasian,
she didn't know what I was laughing at,
but I was left.
You know,
when somebody laughed so hard,
even if you don't get it,
you start laughing.
That's basically what happened.
And you know what just happened there?
You just listened to 34 minutes of my bullshit.
I got you again,
motherfuckers.
All right.
That's the podcast.
Have a great weekend.
You can't,
there's gotta be a little bit
musical interlude here.
And then you're going to listen to another 30 minutes of a greatest hits
Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast possibly released on Saturday.
He made a mighty,
came out 10 years ago,
eight years ago,
or fucking eight minutes ago.
I don't know.
I don't pick them.
All right,
I'll see you on [inaudible]
Monday.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
morning.
What's going on?
It's built birth.
It's the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
January 24th,
2011.
How the hell are you?
How are you doing?
Did you have a good week?
Was the world nice to ya?
Uh,
this is a big day for me.
Everybody.
This is my 100th day when I said I was knocking off the booze because I was
starting to have a big bloated face.
I was like,
fuck this.
I gotta I gotta you know,
gotta get on the treadmill.
I got knock off the booze and I was trying to beat my previous record of going
75 days and this time I said,
fuck it.
I'm going for an even hundred.
And uh,
the goal has been achieved.
Javed chief Javed.
Um,
I'm psyched.
I did it.
And a,
tonight I'm going to the Bruins la kings game down at the staple.
Pheta the most unfriendly fan fucking play she'll ever go to.
It's the haves,
the really haves and the have nots.
I broken it down for you before you got all the corporate seats down low.
Sit next,
Diane Cannon.
Jack Nicholson and fucking sissy space sick.
Whoever the fuck else is down there,
all those Douche bags sitting there with their fucking faces yanked back,
you know,
by the way,
how long has Jack Nicholson had going bald for?
It's just fucking unbelievable how long it took for that guy to go bald.
He lost one hair a day since 1972
so do you ever notice that there's certain people,
it just takes for fucking ever,
unless they seamlessly went into a toupee,
but he's bald.
No,
but you know,
being someone who's balding myself,
you know,
I pay attention to that type of shit and I pay,
pay attention.
All these motherfuckers,
I see the receding hairline,
then all of a sudden it's not there.
The next movie.
And I was like,
there you go.
Look at that guy.
He went out and he got himself sort of a scalped in a user friendly way,
and then they receded the front.
I going out like that.
My goal in life,
I want to look like a Clint Howard.
Okay,
Woo.
It's not going to end good for me.
Uh,
yeah.
So I went a hundred days,
100 days.
Uh,
when a hundred days add a yes.
And I don't know,
I'm afraid I'm scared everyone.
I'm afraid to start drinking again because I noticed that I,
I just pick up where I left off.
Like I really learned about addiction during these last hundred days.
I realized how much shit I was,
uh,
you know,
not,
uh,
addicted to,
to a level that it was like,
you know,
I was coming home and slap it.
My girl around,
you know,
getting on all fours,
growling at my dog as I peed on the stereo.
And then the next morning like I didn't do any time.
I don't remember that.
Huh?
Well maybe I wouldn't drink if you weren't such a cunt,
you know,
I wasn't doing stuff like that.
I was just out having a good fucking time.
I like beer the way I like cake and cookies.
There's really no reason.
There's no reason to have cake or cookies says no nourishment that your body
needs.
You don't need that much fucking sugar.
But a,
I like it.
I like the fucking rush,
you know,
is sitting there feeling gloomy.
I hate myself.
What am I doing?
Remember when I was young and I just go out and play Frisbee and it was fun,
man.
It was simple,
right?
You get older,
you got all this debt,
you got all those bullshit,
everybody's fucking Nag and you,
you get the blues.
So you go out,
you get a slice of cake,
right?
Feeling like shit.
Six bites of cake lady.
You're like,
dude,
I am fucking awesome,
right?
You've got that sugar rush going.
So that's what I realized.
I am a,
I have a number of addictions.
I am addicted to sugar.
Not In like a,
you know,
I need an intervention,
but like I fucking crave it.
But if I lay off it for four days,
when if I don't eat any sweets for four fucking days,
when I look at a doughnut or a piece of cake,
it's like laughable.
Like why the fuck would you eat that?
Look at it.
He at that,
that at,
at,
at that,
there,
it doesn't even look like real food.
You know when you're off,
when you're fucking,
when you've kicked sugar,
when you look at a glazed doughnut,
just sitting there all fucking sweaty.
It just looks,
it looks horrible.
It's like why would you do that to you?
So you know,
you look at all the frosting on a cake,
you,
you make that face like he just sucked on a lemon like Jesus Christ.
Enough already that at fucking cut downstairs just slammed the door cause I'm
being too loud.
I don't care.
Douchebag.
I fucking love old people,
but I hate that motherfucker downstairs.
I fucking hate that guy.
I hate that he's got that classic old person smell.
He does it.
He has a unique smell.
You know what he saw?
He smells like a,
like a fucking,
if you lit a wet dog on fire,
okay,
if you did that,
that's what he smells like.
Fucking miserable motherfucker.
This goddamn Docker's the original Docker's fucking army navy store shop and
douchebag.
Fucking miserable.
Cont giving me the stink eye.
Every time I walk up the fucking walk a can't stand the guy fucking hate him
there.
I hate them.
I don't give a shit.
Right.
I die.
I'll fucking,
you know,
I'll argue that one in the afterlife.
I'll sit right there.
You know,
you drank it drove.
Yes,
I did.
Guilty as charged and treated a lot of women like shit.
You're absolutely right.
Guilty as charged.
And you had a,
you had a poor opinion about the old man downstairs.
Well,
let me tell you something.
Jesus,
you try living above that cunt.
Go Talk to your dad.
He made them,
Ooh God.
Oh,
shut up.
You fucking hippie.
Oh geesh.
Um,
so anyways,
so tonight I am going to,
um,
I'm going to go watch the best of the,
of the,
of,
of the four sports,
the four major sports hockey is the best God damn sport out there.
All right.
And uh,
I know a lot of you won't realize that because you never played it.
You never went to a game,
hence you don't know what you're talking about.
You know,
it'd be like me making fun of line dancing.
I've never done it.
You know,
I've never gone out and bought a pair of wrangler jeans that were fucking $8 and
nine sizes too small for me.
So they cuffed my fucking balls and got out there and stuck my hands in my
pockets and did this little fucking,
that little,
oh my God,
that fucking line dancing.
Can there be a mass suicide amongst line dancers?
Could that just fucking happen in the middle of one of your fucking corn ball?
Stupid ass fucking country music
is country music is,
I don't even know what it's for.
It's for like pod people.
There's absolutely no soul in it whatsoever.
There is aunt.
All right,
they're angry.
Redneck listening to this,
punching the dashboard or your Chevy s 10 all right.
There isn't.
It fucking sucks.
And that line dancing,
we sit there with your fucking thumbs in your fucking pocket and you do that
little I'm do.
I'm,
I'm actually,
I'm in Dallas,
Texas this week,
so let's,
let's go for big air in this one.
We do that then you're fucking,
I wish,
I wish this was a vodcast,
which I'm not doing by the way.
So stop fucking asking me.
The great thing about this thing is you can listen to it while you're doing
other shit,
right?
Are you or are you not doing other shit right now?
Well,
all right then,
are you or are you not pretending to be working right now?
Looking at spreadsheets,
right?
You want to fucking plane,
Huh?
What are your choices for food?
Aren't you doing that as you listen to this when they quit your fucking bitch
and all right,
so anyways,
they do that stupid thing where they banned they're fucking knees and the,
and I can't even think of the fucking music by
[inaudible] the Gig,
the Gig.
You right.
None of the music goes and then they do that little thing where they just one of
their,
one of their feet right there,
right foot.
We'll say the right foot.
It's just pivoting on the heel and the toes of face forward and then to the side
and then back to the front.
Ah.
Then they do that little thing where they bring their fucking foot up and they
spanked the bottom of their foot.
All of them.
He will kills me about those people is they actually think that Jesus loves
them.
I got news for you.
Rednecks.
Jesus is looking the other way.
He's embarrassed.
He's combing his fucking hair into his face.
When he watches you people lined dance.
He is looking that chicken the ring.
Um,
yeah.
So speaking of which I'm going to be,
I completely forgot what the fuck I was talking about.
I know.
Yeah.
I'm going to go into the hockey game tonight.
La Kings first,
the Boston Bruins,
the La Kings,
which who actually have a really good team.
I liked that.
I liked that dude.
Simmons is fucking fastest health and a Kolbe attack.
Um,
border.
It's the greatest fucking game.
And I've actually been playing hockey recently.
Ice Hockey,
the real fucking deal.
And I'm excited.
Guess what?
I learned how to do this week,
42 years of age,
not married,
no kids.
I learned,
finally learned how to stop on both sides.
But you know,
it's funny,
I have,
I have to go buy some more hockey stuff.
You know,
it's funny.
Out here in La,
I have to drive all the way down to like Orange County just to find someplace
that will sell hockey stuff.
Uh,
but I have to,
even though I suck at this sport,
I just,
I'm just an old man and like it takes about four days.
That's how deep the bruises are.
After I'm done falling on the ice.
And like four days after I play,
I look like I've been beaten with a fucking bamboo cane.
I had a brutal one when I was in fucking Atlantic city last weekend doing the
Miami Heat tour of comedy.
Um,
by the way,
um,
the Atlantic city was so successful.
I just got an email today for an offer up in a fox woods for April 30th.
So I will let you know as soon as I find out.
I might actually have an update right now.
Wouldn't that be amazing right here on the fly as you listened to the Monday
morning park?
It's a fuck.
Let's just keep the flow of this podcast going.
I think this was,
I think that's one's gonna be,
it's gonna be a good one.
We're almost 11 minutes in,
things are going well.
For some reason the voice seems way too loud on this thing.
What's going on with this anyways,
um,
yeah,
so I fell on my fucking right ass cheek and hip last time he played before
Atlantic City and uh,
it's one of those seals.
I kept pushing on it going,
I can't believe that didn't bruise.
It's,
it hurts when I touch it.
When I pushed my thumb into my little fucking a right butt cheek,
it hurts.
Right.
And then like four days later I'm in Atlantic city and I'm showering and I
looked out and it looked like somebody threw a can of grape soda at me.
Uh,
so I will be getting all of the hockey stuff,
which I really didn't want to do because,
um,
I don't want to put it out there that I think I know how to play hockey because
I don't,
I just enjoy it.
It's fucking fun.
It's a fast game.
The only equipment I wear is I wear a helmet for my big fucking head and I wear
the full cage in the front because,
uh,
I don't need any hockey scars,
you know,
with the sticks and all that shit.
Why,
why would I do that to myself?
You know,
like I'm going to win a cup.
I need to sacrifice.
Oh,
speaking of which,
I should probably wear a cup too,
right?
No lifting.
Um,
hang on a second.
We're going into the inbox.
Did I get anything?
Nothing.
You motherfucker.
So anyways,
yeah,
so this,
so tonight actually tech,
technically I can start boozing.
This is the 100th day,
but I gotta be honest with you,
I'm not going to do it.
I think I'm going to try to see how long I can go with this.
I'm going to wait until there is an a,
there was a specific event where boozing makes sense and uh,
then I'm going to knock it off.
Then I'm going to pose,
make people,
what am I,
what am I going to do?
Honestly,
I am,
I never going to have a beer for the rest of my life.
I don't know how those people in Aa do it.
That's like,
I have a weird sort of like respect for people in Aa.
And I also have a,
uh,
a disdain for them
because,
uh,
I went to a couple of Aa meetings,
not by choice.
Um,
the judge told me I had to go
as part of your sentence.
Um,
and I went there and uh,
yeah,
I didn't like it.
I kind of liked it.
I liked sort of the room,
kind of like the only aspect of church that I like.
I like going to church because it reminds me not to be a complete piece of shit.
But other than that,
all that stuff about hippies walking on water,
talking to bushes,
it just sounds like an acid trip.
And uh,
it just,
it's just stupid and there's always a fucking leper.
How many fucking lepers were there back then,
Jesus Christ get tell me you wouldn't have a fucking giant stick back in the
day.
Just for the lepers,
you know,
ugh.
Jesus Christ said,
fucking smash them right in there.
Get the fuck away from me.
You fucking leper.
What would Jesus do?
He has the ability to cure himself.
I don't.
All right.
Don't you think that that maybe that's why he was such a good shit because he's
the son of God.
He knows he's going to heaven core seats doing the right thing.
It's so fucking easy to be a good shit when you can walk on water and touch
something and it gets cured.
Of course he's going up and shaking your head.
You fucking freak.
Get away from me.
I can't do that.
You're a leper.
Fuck off Dow.
Go cry to the son of God.
Um,
so anyways,
yeah.
So I would go to these,
these,
these meetings,
these meetings and uh,
you know,
I dunno.
I,
I believe in addiction and then other times I just think,
I don't think all those people addicts,
I think some of them,
they are just weak.
I can't stop myself.
It's like you don't have
like your brain tells you arm to move and pick up something and put it to your
lips.
Right.
Did you guys like alcoholics?
You guys become like such an alcoholic,
like the bottles actually talking to you.
I had a fucking buy into that shit.
Yeah.
You know God damn fucking pussy alcoholics.
All right.
Go drink a case of beer.
I understand it.
Puke it up.
All right.
And then take,
you know,
a week or two off.
Yeah.
You don't do it every night.
You know,
actually I'm full of Shit.
I,
I 100% believe in that,
that addiction thing.
And I actually believe a,
I actually now,
I now understand after watching the biggest loser every season,
I now realize,
yeah,
it is,
it is an addiction.
Because every one of those people has some sort of psychological reason as to
why they do it.
But wait a minute,
I'm not fat,
but I'm out of my fucking mind.
Yeah,
yeah.
So fuck them.
Yeah.
Right.
All right.
Sorry.
I had to work that out.
Fuck those fat fucks.
Eh,
fuck dumb.
I get sad and then I eat 24 cakes.
Well,
how come nobody gets sad and they do set ups.
What's the deal?
I actually,
some people do that.
That's one of the last shows they'll do a gym addictions.
You know,
they'll do something like that cause I think they're out of boring jobs to try
to make exciting.
Have you seen that?
They actually have a show out there right now about people mining for gold.
You know,
I mean,
mining for gold,
obviously they still do it,
but it's like big business now.
They have these sophisticated machines that cut the tops off of mountains and
then they grind them down like you did with you.
A number two pencil in second grade trying to get down to the eraser.
Right?
Okay.
But nobody with a big bushy beard is squatting down like a Chinese gambler next
to a fucking river with the Goddamn dinner plate trying to find gold.
But Lo and behold,
they found 10 douchebags who are doing it.
And they decided to make it a show and they decided to fucking have what film
these guys arguing each other and play this something dangerous is happening.
Music underneath it.
And I'm sick of it.
All right?
Fuck minors.
Fuck people who,
uh,
make cakes for a living.
If fuck those Goddamn crab fishermen get out,
nobody is making you go on that Goddamn boat.
Fucking idiots going out there,
risking your lives,
have a flounder,
you know,
just say what you do out loud for a living.
Just say it out loud a couple of times to yourself.
I go on a fucking tugboat.
Okay.
And I,
I,
I risked my life
to get,
uh,
to get king
crabs.
So rich people have something crunchy to eat.
Go Fuck yourself JP Morgan,
you want crab?
Go get it yourself.
What are you fucking options?
Actually,
you know,
so I'm gonna make a fun.
I actually respect those guys cause I have a tremendous,
tremendous fear of the ocean.
A huge fear of people who go out and swim in the ocean.
You're out of your fucking minds.
I know I've said this before on the podcast,
but you know what I'm going to say.
And again,
I don't give a shit.
I'm edgy.
I'm crazy.
They should make a show about me and my podcast and the dangers of it.
You know,
then me and Neil will have fake arguments.
Um,
yeah,
you know,
we'll have shit like plugs or something will go wrong,
I don't know.
I don't have what we're,
where's my Olympus Ls Ted?
I taught you were going to have it,
then they'll cut to me,
you know,
so I went to go do the podcast and uh,
I couldn't find the Olympus Ellis 10 ditto.
I mean,
I,
I got to get this podcast done by Monday or I don't know what the fuck's going
ahead.
If you notice that,
like I think the Orange County choppers,
they basically created the template for all those reality shows and now
everybody does that shit.
The exact same thing that would happen on that fucking motorcycle show.
Uh,
where the,
where the sun would be like,
Eh,
and then we had a problem,
me a the carburetor,
it didn't fit for the carburetor wasn't here.
And then the bar,
uh,
like the,
the dad comes here,
Yo,
what's going on?
The carburetor isn't here.
Where are you reading
Cobra?
Then he gets on their show.
Mikey's fucking scared.
Well,
no,
why you will fucking cub Raiders.
How fucking jacked is the dad on that show?
He could squeeze my entire family to death if he got excited enough.
Um,
so now they do that shit like it makes sense on the chopper show,
right?
Bunch of mechanics.
They,
they're wearing their greasy Dickies.
They got butt cracks hanging out death.
They're going to yell and scream at each other.
Right?
But the fucking idiots making cakes.
So we get a job,
uh,
we have to make a cake for the firehouse.
And I decided to do a cake that was shaped like a fire hydrant.
I wanted to do a fire hydrant motif with the little a Dalmatian,
you know,
peeing on the fire hydrant.
But Michael was like,
I don't think that we should bring a urine into something that's going to be in
your mouth.
It was typical Michael just shitting on my creative process.
Oh,
kill yourselves.
Nobody cares.
Nobody cares about you and your fucking cakes.
And I like cakes.
Yeah.
Do you guys didn't know that about me?
Did Ya?
Let's see.
How will you with 20 minutes in here 20 minutes into the podcast.
Um,
should I do it?
Should I do it?
Know I'm going to be a class act here.
My condolences to the Chicago bears fans and the fans in New York jets.
Uh,
the true fans,
the true sports fans,
the ones that don't talk shit,
the ones who are cool,
the ones who you know,
you can actually have a conversation about football with my condolences.
Go out to you.
Uh,
believe me as a fan of Boston teams for my entire life,
I know what it feels like to be that fucking clothes and a get kicked in the
seeds against them.
My condolences.
Congratulations to the Steelers and the Green Bay packers.
And uh,
I would like to open this dialogue.
This is something that bugs me about a NFL football is,
is this,
I don't get why in every other fucking major sport.
They count championships from 100 years ago.
Like,
well,
let's look at the red sox.
They,
they won the championship and like 1908 or something.
When they had crazy legs,
McGee was playing fucking third base with his giant Ebenezer fucking mustache.
They count those,
the red sox count five world series titles that we went from 1918 and before
fucking Montreal Canadians.
They Count Stanley cups that they won during that time too.
All right.
The Yankees,
they count all their pre depression era during the depression or whatever.
That's right when they started,
when they count all of those,
the fucking Celtics count,
there's from the 60s the fucking Lakers count their championships,
their first two or three it wasn't even the NBA.
Those are BB eight championships.
Their first four out of five championships.
We're one before the 24 second shot clock even existed when you could win a
basketball game like 17 to 12 they count those.
So my question for spots for sports fans is this,
why don't they count Nfl Championships?
Why do they only count Superbowls?
Because when you just can't super bowls.
The Pittsburgh Steelers are are the Yankees that Canadians are the Celtics of
football.
But it's bullshit.
It's fucking bullshit.
Because the Green Bay packers have won like 12 or 13,
um,
NFL titles and Superbowls.
They won three Superbowls in like another eight or nine NFL titles that for some
reason they don't count.
The Pittsburgh Steelers were in the NFL when Green Bay was winning all those
titles.
So they had a shot at winning them.
You know,
it's as much as I give the Canadian shit going,
I you dominated a 16 league,
which isn't really true.
They were going tit for tat with the maple leafs until 60,
but the Bruins were in that original six.
So we should have dominated and we didn't.
So that's why I shut the fuck up when it comes to that conversation.
So can anybody out there tell me,
why don't they count NFL titles
like I,
I don't,
I don't get that.
I don't get it.
That would be,
if you didn't count that in baseball,
you would have missed out on Babe Ruth,
Mickey Mantle,
Joe Dimaggio,
none of that.
None of that would count.
Bill Russell wouldn't count.
It's fucked up.
I think it's bullshit.
And I think it's,
I think the,
I like,
I want to go to work.
I love sports history.
I want to go to an eagles game and I want to see 1960 NFL champions and I'm not
Kevin Eagles fans,
Shit.
I'm just,
they,
they should have that up there.
The Cleveland browns won it in like a,
I don't like 63 or 64 with Jim Brown.
The bears won one with Mike.
Uh,
Mike Ditka and uh,
what's his face there?
A Dick Butkus right.
They want it.
Uh,
the Green Bay packers won a few.
Then the cults with Johnny Unitas,
you know,
the ones that they won the greatest game ever fucking played Yankee stadium
giants first.
The colts,
1958.
The overtime fucking victory.
Right?
They don't count any of that shit.
It's,
it's disrespectful to the athletes that played.
Those were the best of the best,
at least white guys for,
for most of those years.
But seriously,
there was only one professional league.
So the talent pool was even greater than,
and they don't,
they don't count it.
And I think it's fucking bullshit.
And I'm hoping that somebody talks about that considering you have the most
successful teams since the Super Bowl era,
and then you have playing the most successful team in NFL history.
They have one in every area except for the seventies and eighties.
I guess they didn't want a championship in the 2000,
but they,
but they've been competitive or whatever,
you know,
I don't know.
Speaking of which,
you know,
he guys realize that right now Brett Farve
is getting sued.
Some of this shit.
This is how fucked up the world is right now.
Brett Farve is getting sued by the,
uh,
by two [inaudible] because he tried to get a,
some sort of sexual favors afterwards and they're,
they're,
they're suing for that.
Do you understand that?
The,
let me say that just one more time.
Brett Farve is getting sued by a miss Seuss tumor.
SEUSS's does that.
I said,
my sue says,
um,
mousses um,
tumor suits is for,
for asking basically to,
to,
uh,
you know,
to bang them at the end of it,
there's sewing it.
Could
you fucking believe that?
I just,
it's fuck it was that will you know what that's like?
That's like me showing a comedy club because I got heckled.
It comes with the job.
There was not any much shoes,
any female my suits out there that listens to this podcast.
Are you honestly going to tell me that?
That you've been Robin guys bags in their legs and the chest and all that and
you've,
no one has ever asked you for fucking hand job at the end of it.
It fucking comes with the territory.
That's like being a cop in suing the city cause you got shot at all,
right?
You fucking put hot oil all over a guy's body and you rub everything but their
dick.
I mean,
give me a fucking break.
You got damn cock tease is yeah.
People are gonna ask you to rub one out.
Okay?
And if you had a shred of fucking decency,
you do what?
You complete the Goddamn job.
All right?
Because you're sign says full body massage.
All right,
last I saw my dick is still part of my body.
All right?
You know what the hell.
You know what?
Miss Susie is,
I like,
they like the fucking quarterback who can't get it done,
you know,
just always comes up a little bit short.
They should fucking interview them afterwards.
So,
you know,
like what happened in there?
Eh,
you know,
I just didn't just didn't get it done.
You know,
it was like right there,
all I do is just reach out and grab it.
And I just,
uh,
you know,
we didn't want it.
We didn't want it as much as they wanted it.
Um,
that's just like,
just,
that's such a classic,
uh,
piggyback lawsuit.
It's like once that first stupid whore,
um,
you know,
gave Brett Farve Shit.
This is very interesting that I've noticed about horse.
Once one comes out of the woodwork,
then all of a sudden 20 come out of the woodwork,
you know,
and then they always try to paint it as well.
We were too scared.
We were scared.
Fuck you.
You where you're trying to make money and you're trying to build on the momentum
of the other case.
That's the female version of pulling a train on somebody.
You know,
the guy version is,
you know,
you and 80 or friends,
bang the same girl.
The female version is,
you know,
you're a fucking whore and you're just waiting for a whore to sue a guy that you
fucking banged and then you fucking,
you,
you draft in right behind their lawsuit.
Okay.
Like one of those fucking fairies that rides in that bike race out there in a,
in uh,
in France that just pissed some people off.
Actually.
Do you realize that the level of cardio that you need to compete in that sport
is 10 times that of a professional hockey player?
That's when you know you're watching a sport that no one gives a shit about.
When you have to really start bringing up like science,
they did a study,
the heart rate of the average highlight player.
Oh go fuck yourself.
Why don't you take that highlight thing?
It just fucking cup.
You're nuts.
You're Tate in your asshole and carry yourself out of here.
Why don't you do that?
Does that make sense?
Is that what they do with the highlight sticks
or is it shaped that way?
It's sort of a,
a,
you know,
a user friendly bike seats that you can rock up and down on.
You know what,
I think it's time to read some questions for this week.
I'm going to say I've,
I've exhausted all improv skills at this point.
Oh,
first thing I want to tell you guys,
can you guys do me a huge favor if you're on Facebook?
Um,
there's some douchebag pretending to be me on,
uh,
Facebook.
Uh,
just don't add the guy.
He has a Celtics logo.
I don't know what he's doing.
He's not doing anything malicious.
He's just pretending to be me and it's really weirding me out.
Um,
I mean,
I don't know what he thinks he's good.
I can't get laid off of Facebook,
so I don't know what this,
well,
maybe he's got better typing game than I do,
you know,
but I just don't want that shit to be added to my file down there in Houston,
you know?
All right.
There's a lot of question out there about,
you know,
things that happen within society specially,
this,
this is something that I think a lot of white people need because not because
we're more racist than anybody else,
we just get just the,
the consequences of us fucking up is so much harsher than other people because,
uh,
you know,
we are the gold standard when it comes to racism.
We are in the driver's seat right now.
We have been in the driver's seat for awhile,
basically beating that.
If we are ignorant assholes,
it has way more effect than when other people are.
You know,
back in the day when other people were running shit,
that's the thing,
whoever's on top,
if you're thinking ignorant,
uh,
that's what,
that's why,
you know,
if you're on top and you're thinking ignorant shit,
you have to be called on it because,
uh,
just cause he cause he effect that you can have,
you know what I mean?
Like if somebody from Bangladesh fucking hates me,
that's such a stupid example.
Okay.
That,
that's not a race of people.
I don't even know what Bangladesh's and I gotta be honest with you.
I don't even know if that's a city or a country.
Bangladesh.
Have you ever seen that on the prices,
right?
Yeah.
I want to showcase showdown where selling Yoda,
Bangladesh and some white trash person like myself,
sister with a confused look on their face.
Like I don't know where that is.
Is that where the terrorists are?
I don't want to go there.
Whatever.
Like a Filipino people fucking hate me.
That doesn't affect my life.
It doesn't,
I'm not going to go and do a job interview at,
at,
you know,
Walmart is not run by Filipinos.
You know what I mean?
You know,
not saying there's anything wrong with Filipinos.
All right.
See what,
see what I have to do with this white person.
They'll say,
I'm saying I do about Filipino because we clear here.
I don't know.
I've never had issues.
I to have a lab of gasoline.
I'm a fucking all that shit.
You gotta go to the Jerry Lewis voice there lady.
Um,
so yeah,
people have questions.
So here we go.
And I think all races to chime in,
the questions that you have,
if you have feelings about a different race of people and you just think you're
thinking something funny,
there's nothing malicious,
but is this offensive?
Is it racist?
This is,
this is the new topic.
Okay.
And if you feel that I answered these questions like the ignorant white man that
I am,
uh,
call me out on it.
I'm here.
So here we go.
This first one,
uh,
Bill,
is it racist to call Indians?
Dibbled Dabbous and I'm talking about the Asian ones,
not native Americans.
I'm,
I'm guessing by Debit Dab as you mean
[inaudible] [inaudible] with the bull.
You're saying like that Debbie Dabu.
Um,
is it racist?
Probably,
but it's fucking funny.
So that knocks it down a little bit.
This is what I feel that makes something like racist.
It's like,
like the reason why,
uh,
that one isn't as offensive is because we haven't,
we never enslaved them.
That's the reason why white and black shit is so sensitive is because of the
shit that we did to him.
But we haven't really fuck with those people.
You know?
So
if the black version of that was,
is it,
is it offensive to black people?
Hey man,
mother fucker or whatever.
Yes.
That would be offensive if you did some sort of mocking of the way they spoke.
That would be,
that would be offensive if some CEO was giving a speech and I was driving a,
actually I was having someone else drive my town car and we drove by a group of
a young mother fuckers and uh,
they proceeded to walk forwards.
Yeah,
you'd have to apologize.
So I guess,
yeah,
I guess technically new Manabu like that would be,
that would be offensive.
Is it racist?
Um,
this is what I really,
I really,
it's hard for me to say because [inaudible] had,
it's what's in your heart,
you know,
cause I make fuck I really,
I make fun of,
of everybody,
you know,
I mean,
I play a game out here,
uh,
when someone is make,
let me ask you,
I've got questions for you.
Is this racist?
I have a game out here when I ride around with Nia and she does not approve of
this to keep her in the clear,
she does not approve this.
When somebody makes a more chronic move in front of me,
you know,
driving,
just makes a fucking horrific move.
I play a game called old or Asian
and you have to guess when cause I'm going to pass the person cause I got to see
what they look like.
You know,
whenever somebody does something fucked up,
some comedians do great joke about that.
You just want to see what the fuck they look like.
Right.
Uh,
that's the game.
Older Asian.
So as I speed up my little hybrid to try to pull parallel to them,
I always say,
what do you say?
You,
what are you going with all the ration?
What do you got?
Older regime.
She goes,
I'm not playing this game.
That's Maine.
And then I was gone.
I'm going to go with old and then I pull up,
oh it's fucking Asian.
You know?
Or Oh I nailed it.
It was an old guy.
So,
uh,
is that racist?
I'm sure it's offensive,
but within the context of my own car,
you know,
I'm not yelling at anybody and I got to admit,
there's a lot of truth in the fucking game.
Yeah.
Jesus,
I'm gonna have to apologize next week on the podcast.
So I would say that,
uh,
Indian people,
why don't you chime in?
I would say that,
yeah.
That they would find that they would find that offensive.
Um,
is it racist?
Let me see if I can use it in a sentence here.
Hey,
uh,
you know,
I called up customer service and uh,
one of those stupid dub was answered and tried to tell me that his name was
Steve and act like he was in Kentucky.
But I,
I know that he was actually an India,
cause what he talked to you is go double double words.
How can I help you?
Um,
is it racist?
Probably.
You know what,
something bad has to happen between white culture and,
uh,
or,
or western culture and Indians.
So,
you know what I mean?
It's like a,
it's like you're playing a team and there's no rivalry.
Like patriots verse jets this year was like a whites and blacks.
It was bad.
It was a lot of hate,
you know,
but like patriots verse like the Fucking Lions,
you know?
Yeah.
There's gotta be some shit targets.
It's knocked out,
but it still hurts if somebody says something mean.
I don't,
I really don't.
What the fuck I'm talking about?
All right,
let's move to the next one.
The next one on the new controversial topic on the Monday morning podcast.
Is it racist?
All right,
here we go.
Um,
Bill,
I had an interesting experience today apparently involving me as a racist.
I was walking with two of my coworkers who are both black.
Old G is,
here we go.
Um,
we were going to go get some lunch.
One of my coworkers who I'm also friends with,
uh,
did a little high five fist bumps shuffle with one of the female six security
guards at the front desk.
Knowing both of them and how they interact with one another.
I kind of made a in passing comment to the tune of man,
you guys in your handshakes while obviously laughing,
laughing while obviously laughing at just how choreographed it was in more or
less picturing them in a studio or something,
working out the logistics to get the fucking handshake.
Perfect.
Anyways,
we all laughed and moved on and we got our lunch.
All right,
so nothing wrong yet.
So you're cool with these people.
You made a joke and everybody laughed.
No problems,
no problems so far.
Um,
however,
after coming back through secure,
uh,
back through security,
I noticed the security guard stopped me and Kinda had a scowl on her face.
I thought she was mad at me for something,
but it turned out she was mad at this other lady who was black because she
overheard my comment and was telling,
uh,
that security guard that she couldn't believe I had the nerve to say something
like that.
And I should be ashamed also to the point where she could,
um,
almost to the point where she could actually go complain to the human resource
people because she was offended,
um,
et cetera without even considering that.
Maybe just maybe I was talking about the security guard and my coworker and not
all black people now.
It being corporate America in all I'm sure rather than even face the possibility
of any bad press,
they'd rather just sweep me out the door and completely ruined my re any
reputation I may or may not hold at the company just to save their own asses.
I feel I did nothing wrong and had no intentions of ever doing anything wrong.
Anything wrong,
I'm not going to go on and on about how I kiss black babies and try to
rehabilitate inner city schools because I don't,
but I'm certainly not some corn fed rebel flag waving ignorant product of what
might be incest.
I guess my question is do we really have to walk on eggshells when we are just
making casual conversation that just any that just any con can pick apart,
select the context that they might think it is in and then start crying foul.
Basically.
I would have liked to call that woman a con and told her to go fuck herself.
Well,
let's just say I was already kind of worried about my job.
I'll write,
see,
um,
yeah,
I think this is,
this is the classic one where you were fucking around the other two people knew
you were fucking around,
but that one person decides to get offended and then you have to go on TV and
apologize.
Which personally I think is the wrong move because when you apologize now it's
like you're,
you're admitting that you meant it in a bad way.
I mean,
the apology I would do there and say,
look,
you know,
I'm sorry that you didn't understand that I was joking,
but I'm not going to sit here and apologize like I have any,
any sort of ill will come in your way,
you know,
but I,
but just to avoid the problem in the future,
uh,
white people do not use the expression you guys or you people
when talking about black people,
that's just,
it's just not going to,
you're,
you're setting yourself up for someone to get offended.
And,
um,
there's a weird sort of a push poll going on with that whole,
uh,
you guys in new people thing where,
um,
with somebody white says that there becomes this concern of,
that you're separating.
You're separating like,
yeah,
you know,
you people over there with how you live your lives and where over here,
black people have that weird relationship with white people where they're like,
you know,
can you stop stealing our fucking music and our culture?
Eh,
but then like,
if something,
you know,
hey,
let's pave the streets,
you know,
well,
make sure you do it in our neighborhood.
We're all in this together,
right.
All of us together.
You know what I mean?
So let's set weird sort of fucking push pull thing going on.
So yeah,
just avoid,
uh,
avoid the whole fucking,
um,
yeah,
you fucked up.
You did fuck up,
but you left yourself open for a sucker punch by saying you guys,
you know,
uh,
that's,
I guess that that's what it is.
I don't know.
That's,
that's,
that's my,
I basically a white guy telling a white guy how he fucked up.
So black people feel listened to this thing.
Uh,
please,
please help me out here.
Did I basically get it right?
Is that essentially it?
And I know most people wouldn't get offended.
Uh,
but that,
that's one of those things like that girl getting offended and then you've got
to worry that you're going to lose your job.
It's like those fucking piggyback whores who massage guys for a living.
You know,
some of those messsage state,
they'll actually come to your house and give you a full body rubbed down with
oil.
Okay.
And then have the fucking nerve to get upset that you try to get a hand job,
the end of it,
you know,
give me a fucking break.
Why don't you fucking misuse broads man the fuck up and start rubbing one out?
Is it that God damn hard,
no pun intended.
Is it that fucking difficult
to just fucking,
you know,
it's like you're revving a motorcycle.
That's it.
That's all you gotta do.
Up and down,
up and down with that dead fucking oil.
You in and out.
You want that house on the hill,
sweetheart?
There's a price to pay.
All right.
Now when a quarterback who owns every fucking record,
good and bad in the Goddamn universe,
asked you to rub one out.
God Damn it.
You fucking rub one out.
Well maybe you don't blog in this business sister.
That's right.
Stare at your fucking manicured toes.
Pedicured whatever the fuck you supposed to say.
Um,
Jesus Christ mean spirited.
Alright,
so there you go.
That's the new,
that's a new topic.
Is it racist?
And I would to hear,
um,
some honest comments from a non white people about their thoughts.
You know
the fucked up ones too.
Okay.
Cause I've watched enough spike Lee movies to think that evidently it's just us.
But I've hung around enough people from different races to realize,
oh yeah,
everybody's like this.
Everybody has their little fucked up thoughts.
You guys ever see that Broadway play?
They got that song.
Everybody.
Everyone's a little bit racist.
What does that the alphabet city one,
whenever the fuck it's called.
I actually enjoyed that,
actually went to a Broadway musical and there was puppets in it and I had a
great time.
How about that?
What does that say about me?
Um,
all right,
let's get on with advice.
Advice for this week.
All right,
advice bill.
Let me set this one up for you cause it gets a little complicated over there.
Um,
I went to a New Year's Eve party with my best friend of 13 years.
Oh Jesus.
Oh by the way,
this guy uses so many fucking names.
I'm just going to use the names.
All right.
I know I don't name names,
but fuck this guy.
There's like 15 fucking names and then he goes back to the first name,
back to the seventh name.
So fuck it.
I'm naming names.
All right,
so here we go.
I'm suspending that rule much like they suspended the salary cap and NFL
football this year.
Same Way.
All right.
All right,
Bill.
I went to a New Year's Eve party with my best friend of 13 years mark.
I got really drunk and hooked up with my friend John's ex girlfriend,
Anna John and Anna had dated for two years.
John broke up with Anna back in September rather harshly and immediately started
banging other girls and,
and I also work together.
Oh Gee.
And we've become good friends.
Here we go.
So hooking up seemed inevitable.
Our friends have even joked about it.
Hey,
if you guys like fucked each other yet,
you guys want to get wings.
Um,
anyway,
I had been dating this girl Sarah since October.
We never got too serious.
We kind of agreed to take a break when she left to go to London for spring
semester.
Mark's girlfriend who happened to be a cunt is best friends with Sarah.
All right.
Are you like me?
Are you're already lost?
Are there too many fucking names here?
Let's go back to the beginning.
Mark and I got really drunk.
No,
I went to a newsy party of my best friend mark.
I got really drunk and hooked up with okay.
Marks.
His friend John has the ex-girlfriend.
All right.
It was like a fucking mini series they had to show you clips from last week.
Um,
so anyways,
he's dating some current named Sarah.
They agreed to take a break
and the girl,
you're taking a break with his best friends with your friend's girlfriend mark.
Okay,
I got it.
All right.
I'm up to speed here.
So at this party and an eye,
this is John's ex and an I get pretty drunk and start making up.
None of our friends were there except for
Mac Mac site and got upset you fucking pussy and just had to leave.
Oh my God.
Really?
Like some 15 year old girl.
Exactly.
Anna and I went to her place and proceeded to do some stuff.
We didn't bang that night,
but oral sex and whatnot was traded and we passed out.
We both agreed that nobody needed to know what happened.
I went to Mark's house later,
New Year's day and said nothing happened with Anna and I and I,
and by the way,
we just made out.
I figured that was enough for him to know,
not to tell anyone,
especially his fucking girlfriend.
Neither of US brought it up for the next four days and it seemed like everything
was fine.
Couple of days passed out of nowhere.
Mark asked me if I was going to tell John that Anna and I made out.
I was sort of taken aback as you should have been
sort of taken aback by the question,
but I told them I hadn't planned on it.
He said he wouldn't tell John if I didn't because he didn't want to be a bad
friend.
All right,
good man.
I told him that it wasn't a big deal that we just made out and he was being a
huge bitch.
That was a bad move on your part.
Even though he was being a huge bitch.
You shouldn't have said that.
All right.
Because he's acting like a fucking chick right here and hell has no fury like a
woman scorned and you just score in that fucking bitch man right there.
All right,
so you can guess where the fuck this is going.
Okay.
And then asked him if he told his girlfriend about it and of course he said yes.
When I asked him why the fuck he did that,
he said,
because I needed to know if I should tell John Jesus Christ.
I proceeded to call him a bitch.
Good man.
And let them know how much of a bitch move it was to tell his girlfriend.
Especially since he acted like everything was fine for four days.
Yeah,
this guy is beyond a pussy.
This is the kind of guy who like,
you know,
does he like Bake Brownies?
See One of those guys who like doesn't mind going shopping with his fucking
girlfriend.
You know,
it's funny that I just said that I actually,
I'll bake brownies in a fucking second.
I'm such a fucking hypocrite.
All right,
let's,
let's finish this.
All right.
Nobody needed to know about what happened and now he told his girlfriend,
Sarah,
um,
uh,
this isn't my fault.
Once again,
he fucked up the sentence.
Nobody needs to know about what happened and now he told his girlfriend Sara
would definitely find out.
I knew Sarah wouldn't care about me.
Drunkenly hooking up with Anna,
but it's still something she didn't need to know.
Oh,
Sarah is the fucking Twat and went to Europe.
Somehow I was able to leave mocks house without beating the shit out of him.
I called John who was spending winter break in El Paso and told them what's,
what happened.
He said he didn't really give a shit and agreed it was fucked up for mark to say
anyone,
anything to anyone,
especially as girlfriend.
When I told mark he could have asked anyone else about whether or not his bitch
ass should tell John what happened.
He said he asked his girlfriend so he could get a serious opinion as if being
told to keep your fucking mouth shut.
You little girl from either one of you,
either one of our tenants.
So close guy friends wouldn't have been a serious enough opinion anyways.
I just needed your validation and how much of a bitch mark was about the whole
thing.
Also,
Anna and I decided to start sneaking around and are banging each other.
No harm,
no foul.
Feel free to add onto the story of him and you read any podcasts.
Yeah,
Dude.
that's,
yeah,
that guy right there at that guy.
You need to cut out of the loop.
Okay.
That is,
um,
that's it.
You,
you forfeited your fucking guy card.
It's over.
You can't be trusted.
You think like a woman,
which is fine.
There's nothing wrong with thinking like a woman,
but just go hang out with a bunch of women now.
What a fucking,
ugh.
Do the amount of shit that has gone down that I have fucking,
I am so buried in me that I don't even remember it.
The Mount of fucking shit
is ridiculous and I don't even bring it up when it's me and just the other dude
who did the,
the dirty shit.
I'll fucking bury it in a second.
I know exactly how to do it.
When I meet your fucking wife or your girlfriend.
I'll fuck yeah.
Fucking look you right in the AIAA,
sweetie.
How are you?
You look great.
You've been going to the gym at that.
Fantastic.
I'll tell your guy is such a sweetheart.
God Damn it.
The other day there was a cat stuck in the trees.
The first guy up to even wait for a letter,
a just started climbing up there.
What a swell guy.
Even if it's a Dick,
even if it's a fucking Dick,
what I'll then do is I'll just avoid his girlfriend,
but I'm not fucking bring it up to that guy.
Really needs to go get his fucking tubes tied.
What a fag.
All right.
Two
youtube videos of the week.
Youtube.
Um,
all right.
This one is fucking absolutely insane.
And if this was made by white people,
this would actually be considered racist on some level,
but it was actually made,
I don't know if it's Japanese,
Chinese people,
whatever the name of the video is,
how to poop.
And it is an animated cartoon teaching children how to,
uh,
go poopy in the toilet and it is fucking insane.
It's fucking insane.
It's great.
If you really have a problem in your life that is just weighing on you and it's
sucking the energy out of you and you just need to clear every thought from your
brain.
Please watch how to poop.
Just go to the M podcast.com we've got all these videos.
This is,
that's the official fan site of the Monday morning podcast.
Uh,
just please go and watch this thing.
It's fucking awesome.
Uh,
we got really good,
I got three really good youtube videos this week.
The next one is,
uh,
this guy made a federal reserve music video that you have to see.
It's a,
he's doing basically assigned parody of the police's a song.
Every breath you take,
it's fucking great.
The guy actually has a really good voice.
This is fucking funny as hell.
Now the great one.
And then the last one is,
uh,
it's just a highlight video of Jim Brown and there's so many,
um,
fans that say Jim Brown is overrated and he couldn't play in today's NFL.
You just look at this highlight reel,
the balance and the power that this guy has is,
it's unfucking.
He,
he's like running sideways half the time or running backwards,
just plowing over people.
The combination of balance of power is like,
it's,
it's foreshadowing to Earl Campbell,
Earl Campbell's the only guy I've seen with like runs like this.
And for everybody who thinks Jim Brown couldn't play,
now you're,
you're 100% wrong and I know what you're gonna do.
You're gonna look at how tall he was and how much he weighed and say he would
get crushed in today's NFL.
That's the wrong way to look at it.
If he took Jim Brown and you put them in the modern era,
which you have to do is also give them all the modern trade,
uh,
nutrition,
all the modern sports science and all of that.
So he would look like today's NFL football with his,
with his skills,
his God given strength and balance,
and he would fucking tear up the goddamn league.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I don't want to hear another argument.
I'm sick of people bringing up fucking guys from nowadays where they're taken
fucking horse Trancle tranquilizers and you tell him he would have dominated in
1950 I would have dominated in 1950.
Somebody 50 years from now could dominate the NFL right fucking now bigger.
Yeah.
It's called advancement.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Morons.
Alright.
Overrated.
Underrated for this week.
Every minority and woman in commercials playing the straight man to the dumb
white guy.
I'm not racist or misogynistic in the least bit,
but enough is enough.
Uh,
dude,
that's fucking hilarious.
And that's another thing that uh,
that's not minorities or women's fault.
That's because of all the fucked up shit white people have done and we don't
want to get sued.
That's why they're doing it.
Not because they're trying to be sensitive to other sexes or other races.
They just make the white guy be the stooge and all these fucking commercials
cause they don't want to get sued.
But yeah,
it's starting to get annoying.
There's always like the black guy shaking his head as the fucking white guys
slamming himself in the face with like a fucking rake.
That's not the way you though it.
Um,
that was actually a man,
woman one,
remember that one where the woman's sit there at the computer and that their
husband is outside fucking,
he's got to go.
There's a beehive,
any stake taking like a broom handle and he's shoving it up the fucking beehive.
And then he gets stung and she's sitting there rolling her eyes like,
ah,
my husband,
he's a fucking retard.
Uh,
and they do that between men and women and race and the fucking,
uh,
the white dude always has to be the moron.
But I mean,
you know,
it is what it is,
but you know,
you should be happy white person who wrote that,
that they had that.
That's the way they balance it out.
You know,
you're still winning,
so quit your fucking crying.
All right.
Also overrated in real life and not what I see on TV is the female carpenter or
construction worker I get,
I get that you've got to make up and try harder for all the bullshit you deal
with.
For Fuck's sake.
Crack a smile for once in your life.
I really don't know what he's bitching about.
Their female construction workers don't smile enough.
Um,
alright.
Underrated the PJ's Eddie Murphy was brilliant and the claymation was the shit
back in the day.
Why the fuck don't,
why the fuck that show isn't on DVD is a crime to all comedy.
One of the few shows that is actually better with closed caption on a number two
real musicians.
Anybody remember these people that naturally play actually play their
instruments and none of that fucking auto tuners,
sampling machine and turntables,
all of those are not fucking instruments.
Um,
wow.
I mean,
you know,
I've actually come to a place where I can,
I can understand the brilliance of being able to take pieces of,
so I think the way that the Beastie boys did it on Paul's Boutique where you
took like 10 or 12 different samples,
looped them together and created a new song.
I mean,
there is there that is a talent,
you know,
turn tables.
That's just,
I don't get that shit.
I don't understand that.
Um,
I'm too fucking all to get that and I don't get,
I don't get mashups.
I've,
I bitched about that before.
Mashups are the emperor's new clothes of music.
Okay.
All you have to do is pick two songs that are the same temple.
Okay?
Same beats per minute.
Then the lyrics will fit on that other one.
Then all you have to do is just one that where the lyrics fit the mood of the
new music.
You're putting it over.
That's not that fucking difficult.
If he got sad sort of music,
pick another sad fucking song and just stick that music under those sad lyrics.
As long as the tempo is the same and yeah,
it's going to work out.
Daddy took jingle bells and blended it with Santa Claus is coming to town.
MMM.
What else do we got?
A road trip.
Road trips with you.
Fucking bug buddies never gets old.
That's,
that's absolutely true.
That's why the hangover was such a great fucking movie.
A real lemonade.
Not that coke and Pepsi packaged garbage,
but real shit with fucking pulp and flavor.
I like this guy.
This guy's into old shit.
You know a pen and paper.
Not This fucking laptop horse shit.
I don't remember my laptop ever crash and I've actually said that.
Um,
all right,
that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
Everybody,
I hope you had a great week.
Um,
and once again,
I'm looking forward to,
to the,
uh,
the Steelers Greenbay championships and do me a favor bring up all green bay's
NFL titles.
I would really like to try to start an underground debate about that because I
want them to start counting NFL titles and I want to see NFL franchises fly
those NFL championship flags.
You want it,
you know,
I didn't think the AFL one should fly those flags.
It's part of the history.
You're a fucking nerd.
Like me.
I liked that type of shit.
I'm actually reading a book right now called the greatest game by Richard
Bailey.
Ah,
somebody gave me this book and uh,
it's actually about the Bucky dent red sox.
Um,
that one,
one day playoff game.
And you know,
that's a great thing about the red sox finally winning a world series and
they're wanting another one.
I can actually sit back and read this book and it is,
um,
it's a fucking great read.
It's a great read.
I recommend it.
All right.
That's it.
That's a podcast for this week.
Everybody have a great week.
I'm at the Improv and Addison,
Addison,
Texas this week.
And,
uh,
what else do I got coming up that's go on my website.
Hang on one second.
Come on guys.
Hang in there.
Don't shut it off just yet.
All right.
Um,
then going to be at the count Basie theater in Red Bank,
New Jersey on February 18th,
and I'm going to be at the new,
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
we in Tarrytown music hall on the 17th of February,
Miami beach.
We have a new theater.
Um,
they had me booked in another one,
but they had already booked another act there,
so they had to switch it up.
I'm actually going to be at the new World Symphony Theater,
uh,
on 17th Street,
Miami Beach,
Florida on the,
the 4th of March.
The Tower Theater in Philadelphia.
The guy.
I've got a bunch of new dates on the website,
tower theater in a Philadelphia on April 9th.
And um,
this is the last one here.
I'm going to be at the paps.
Fuck.
Ah,
Jesus Christ,
the linkedin work.
I would be at the,
you know,
I was having such a great podcast too.
On April 22nd I'm going to be at the PABST theater in Milwaukee,
Wisconsin.
Um,
and right off the bat,
I just want to tell you,
I'm blown away about how many tickets sold the first day.
Uh,
Milwaukee was one of those cities where I was like,
you know,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if I'm gonna sell tickets there.
You know,
it's not like New York.
It's not Chicago,
it's not La,
you know,
so it's not one of those kinds of cities,
but I don't,
it doesn't strike me as a gator dad kind of city either.
It's one of those middle ground ones.
So I don't know where the fuck I'm going to fit in it.
So I want to thank everybody in Wisconsin who went out and bought tickets.
MMM.
Especially,
Oh,
you know what?
Somebody sent me a fucking email if I can just from Escanaba Michigan saying
they were coming all the way down because they remembered back in the day.
I played a college up there and the upper peninsula of Michigan and they said,
uh,
I went up in front of 17 people in a cafeteria and evidently I killed.
So the fact that I actually put on a show in front of 17 people,
see how it,
see how that new comedians,
if you're listening to this podcast,
those fucking shows matter.
Years later,
they'll actually show up if you give them hell in front of 11 people doing a
nooner in the upper peninsula,
Michigan.
I actually fucking remember that Gig.
I did a couple of gigs up there though.
That's an amazing group of people who live up there.
I like how they embrace winter.
They really have no choice,
but they actually get real fucking a snow storms.
You know where you come out,
you open your door,
you know,
and you get buried by like nine feet of fucking snow.
You're walking down the street on your snow shoes and you're stepping over like
frozen elk.
Right.
You know,
and they just stay.
Just stay.
Embrace it.
Yeah.
As opposed to all the pussies down here,
every time there's four inch is a fucking snore.
Every god damn fatty is running down to the fucking supermarket.
Like they're going to starve to death.
I just want one news guy.
During all that insanity,
we're going to get six to eight inches.
It's like,
do you realize six to eight inches of snow it that would barely reach the
average person's up to their calf.
And considering you can last about 35 days without food as long as he had,
as long as you have water.
Okay.
And Snow is water.
Stick it in your mouth.
See what happens.
All right.
You gotta be fucking fine.
So sit tight.
Okay.
All right.
Their sport.
That's what I wanted to say.
I want to,
I want them to just fucking sit there and watch the weatherman losing his
fucking mind.
All excited that he's the focus this week on the Goddamn fucking newscast.
Right?
Or that night or the newscast.
And then when they go back to the anchor,
who's fucking co-anchor cause he's the god Damn Alpha male.
I want them to dress down that fucking that goddamn a weatherman,
four inches of snow.
Jesus Christ.
I could stick my dick in that.
You could still see the shaft.
The fuck are you talking about?
Go Fuck Yourself.
All right,
that's it.
That's a podcast for this week.
You guys have a great weekend yet.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Don't take any shit.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].